scènes d'adieu devant le commissariat de
vesoul des membres du collectif des dés
de défense des migrants sont venus
accompagnés de guinéens sous le coup
d'une expulsion décidée par le préfet de
haute saône en ce 1er mai présent mais
impuissant je suis triste de voir que
c'est pas le premier c'est pas le
dernier est en colère contre l'état
français
parce que en fait cette personne était
vraiment souffrance et n'a même pu même
pas pu demander l'asile en france
comme les 37 autres exilés soutenus par
le collectif sékouba est arrivé en
europe par l'italie avant de venir en
france en août dernier est à l'épée
dames à occuper de nous maintenant et va
nous mettre dehors encore on va
commencer a dormi dehors comme à avoir
puisque et lorsque j'étais en italie
avant je fais quatre mois au campo et
puis je fais moi doit aussi avant de
venir j'ai dormait dans la gare train et
pourtant c'est bien là que le renvoi
l'état français sékouba et du bli née du
nom du règlement dublin qui oblige les
migrants à déposer leur demande d'asile
dans le pays par lequel ils sont arrivés
le règlement dublin le règlement dublin
mais des hommes et des femmes et des
enfants parce que ça concerne aussi les
familles dans des situations kafkaïennes
ils ont aucun choix après heureusement
il ya des préfectures qui sont un peu
plus humaine un peu plus respectueuse
des droits de l'homme et qu'il ait des
du bling qui leur permettent de demander
l'asile mais ce n'est pas le cas en
haute saône ce soir six coups bas et son
ami dormiront centre de rétention de
metz avant d'être renvoyé peut-être dès
demain en italie